nikon manufacturier américain qui
cherche à se redéfinir
mise à prix en europe
compression 12 milliards de dollars de
son action l'an passé
faute veut se relancer en misant sur les
voitures de l'avenir un vent de
modernisme et supplie par l'arrivée dans
l'industrie automobile de centaines de
petites entreprises en démarrage et
d'ondjiva trees d'ottawa le projet né
dans un sous sol il y a 6 ans fait
tourner la tête des grands constructeurs
qui sont intéressés cet adaptateur
capable de recharger les piles
électriques en dix minutes sans diminuer
leur durée de vie le contingent
technologique canadien comprend aussi
des représentants de centres de
recherche dont celui de l'université de
toronto sur les véhicules électriques
dans le laboratoire de la ville reine on
cherche à créer des bornes de recharge
sans fil ainsi qu'à transformer les
voitures électriques en source d'énergie
capable d'alimenter une résidence du
raft foxconn faut créer de la valeur
ajoutée explique le co directeur du
centre de recherche
la transformation de l'industrie
automobile canadienne s'accélère
constate cet analyste
avec la spécialisation que le pays
essaie de se donner en termes
d'intelligence artificielle et de
composants liée est la cause de
tottenham ensemble qui a peut-être un
filon aller chercher en notant que le
canada prenne sa place répond l'ancien
tsar de l'automobile au pays qui
souhaiteraient que les entreprises
canadiennes mettent encore plus d'effort
pour se faire connaître à
l'international
on n'est pas assez agressif pour
pour ça on a fait faux être faut être le
plus visible la transformation de
l'industrie automobile canadienne ne se
fait pas sans douleur
2600 employés de general motors perdront
leur emploi plus tard cette année en
raison de la fermeture de l'usiné
d'oshawa
il continue de se battre pour sauver
leur gagne pain prend des décisions pour
cette sphère wall street déplore-t-il
les canadiens n'accepte pas ça mais
d'autres fois ils refusent de se battre
pour ces milliers d'emplois
traditionnels le premier ministre
ontarien veut plutôt protéger les autres
juges n manufacturière de la province et
favoriser les investissements des grands
constructeurs dans leur centre de
recherche
il vante auprès du secteur automobile un
climat plus propice aux affaires en
ontario depuis son élection le moment le
plus prisé de la présentation de fold le
dévoilement de son modèle le plus
puissant jamais construit pour la route
malgré tout l'industrie automobile ne
peut s'empêcher de poursuivre son
histoire d'amour avec les grosses
cylindrées traditionnel ici philippe
leblanc radio-canada détroit